el aumento del nivel del mar por el
cambio climático llegó a un punto de no
retorno según la ONU
desafortunadamente estas tendencias
negativas en los patrones climáticos
pueden continuar hasta 2060
independientemente de nuestro éxito en
la mitigación del cambio climático
más de 10 centímetros ha aumentado el
nivel del mar desde la década de 1990 y
sólo entre 2013 y 2022 los niveles
globales aumentaron a más del doble del
Ritmo que lo hicieron en la primera
década de mediciones entre 1993 y 2002
las principales causas del aumento son
el derretimiento los glaciares y los
niveles récord de calor en los océanos
por la acumulación de dióxido de carbono
en la atmósfera entre otros gases de
efecto invernadero
el cambio climático es una realidad y su
impacto se siente cada vez más dicen
estos activistas liderados por extinción
rebelión y greenpeace frente al
parlamento del Reino Unido en Londres
exigiendo al gobierno que detenga las
nuevas licencias de exploración de
petróleo y gas y que Escucha la ciencia
cuando
India a visitar a mis padres se siente
como meter la cabeza en el horno hace 48
grados a veces 50
y cuando camino por Londres me siento
como en una especie de película
distópica
El día de la tierra llega luego de
semanas de clima extremo con
temperaturas que alcanzaron un récord de
45 grados Celsius en Tailandia y
produjeron olas de calor en India
dejando al menos 13 personas muertas la
Organización meteorológica Mundial y el
grupo intergubernamental de expertos
sobre el cambio climático prevén que
este año podría registrarse un nuevo
récord de altas temperaturas por el
inicio del efecto del niño superando al
verano de 2022 que pasó a la historia
como el más caluroso en Europa desde que
se tienen registros